hey wisecrack Jared here and today we're
taking a fresh look at the 1995 classic
that seamlessly combined mind-bending
metaphysical themes and cartoon boobs
ghost in the shell' yeah we know there's
a new version out but apparently they
forgot to put in a lot of the brainy
stuff so we decided to talk about the
original many have weighed in over the
years on what the film says about the
line between human and machine but
that's not what we're talking about
today instead we're going to examine the
film's warning about humanity's
potentially fatal flaw and its roadmap
for a more evolved civilization ghost in
the shell' is probably one of the most
philosophically complex animated films
out there so big shout out to Naruto
Online for sponsoring this video and
supporting us as we tackle this cultural
milestone since some of the philosophy
will be covering can get a bit confusing
stick around till the end to hear us
explain a key lesson using the world of
Naruto welcome to this wisecrack vision
on the philosophy of ghosts in the shell
and as always spoilers ahead ghost in
the shell had a huge impact on sci-fi
work such as ex machina the matrix and
Westworld echo not only the film's
aesthetics but also the theme of mankind
versus technology we often see this as a
warning that technology will take over
and/or alter humanity for the worse and
I'm not talking about click bait or
selfies I'm talking about this the
machines had found all the energy they
would
and this you know classic robot
overlords stuff
however ghost in the shell' is different
while it's set up to be a typical battle
between man and his creation the
resolution is not one side triumphing
over the other but a synthesis between
the two don't remember can't blame you
it's probably been a while but here's a
quick refresher the film centers around
major moto ko Kusanagi a cyborg
government agent working for section 9
basically a black ops unit section 9
pursues a mysterious entity known as the
puppet master who employs ghost hacking
to monkey around with people's memories
and force them to do its bidding do you
even know who you are
ghost hat humans are so pathetic it's a
shame and this poor bastards been hacked
pretty badly this super hacker turns out
to be a spy program originally called
Project two five zero 1 which was
secretly developed by section 6 there an
Intelligence Division sort of like the
CIA section 6 lost control of their
creation after it spontaneously
developed self-awareness by swimming in
the vast ocean of the digital world
when Kusanagi finally catches up to the
puppet master it makes a rather forward
proposal I want us to merge that they
should merge consciousnesses and create
a new unique being she accepts and the
film ends with a new entity call it the
coos enough--it master contemplating
what to do next maybe a vacation the
confrontation and resolution of these
two forces human and digital
consciousnesses reflects German
philosopher Georg Wilhelm Friedrich
Hegel vision of progress
what a name to Hegel conflict progresses
human history every development from the
time of our illustrious forefathers to
the present day
is caused by forces that clash and
create something new this is Hegel's
dialectics in a nutshell but before we
get into that we need to show how
Hegel's fundamental ideas help build the
setting of ghosts in the shell
first and foremost Hegel's philosophy is
driven by the belief that the world
operates on rational principles and that
the true nature of reality is knowable
Kusanagi is defined by this
philosophical idealism she is driven by
dissatisfaction with her limited
perspective any way you look at it
the information that a person
accumulates in a lifetime is just a drop
in the bucket and is convinced that
there is a more perfect reality
available to her as such the film treats
the marriage of kusanagi's human
consciousness and the puppet masters
artificial nature with a certain
optimism and Hegel's system of
dialectics explains why but first I
wanted to Singlish Hegel dialectics from
the way the term is more commonly
understood in classical philosophy
dialectics are a form of argumentative
discourse designed to ferret out
contradictions and arrive at a better
understanding of truth you start with an
argument called a thesis which is met by
a counter argument called an antithesis
the end result may be either a
refutation of the original idea and
affirmation of the counter argument or a
synthesis of the assertions that results
in a better understanding of the subject
Thanks Socratic method or a lawyer
cross-examining a witness the purpose is
to learn the truth in Hegel system
dialectics is more than just
philosophical inquiry they are the very
mechanism by which humans progress both
on an individual level and as a
collective when one force confronts
another force something new ultimately
emerges at the heart of the film is a
dialectic of the human and digital world
in the one corner we have Kusanagi and
her human mind her various memories and
experiences combined to make her a
unique individual and yet she feels
constrained by her own limited personal
identity each of those things are just a
small part of it I collect information
to use in my own way all of that blends
to create a mixture that forms me and
gives rise to my conscience I feel
confined only free to expand myself
within boundaries in the other corner we
have the puppet master who sprang forth
from the vast informational resources of
cyber reality and therefore possesses
the broader understanding that Kusanagi
seeks but the puppet master too feels
limited by its lack of personal identity
I refer to myself as an intelligent
life-form because I am sentient and I'm
able to recognize my own existence but
in my present state I am still
incomplete I lack the most basic life
processes inherent in
living organisms reproducing and dying
in short each has what the other needs
other films have us trained to think
that when technology gets a little too
big verse britches it needs to be put in
its place
so humanity can be preserved but through
the lens of Hegel's master-slave
dialectic this meeting of the minds
should have no winner
imagine a feudal lord of the Middle Ages
and the serfs bound to work his fields
the Lord is the master he can force the
serfs to toil away because he controls
all the agriculture in the area the
serfs are his slaves peasants who can't
afford land of their own they worked
their asses off while the Lord sits back
with her refreshing drink sounds great
for the Lord right well the problem is
as the serfs labor they become better at
better at farming while the master
learns nothing new he stagnates while
the serfs become more powerful due to
their valuable knowledge this according
to Hegel is what leads the oppressed to
overcome their masters still not making
sense well stick around to the end to
hear it explained in the context of
Naruto examples of oppressive masters
and usurping slaves resonate throughout
ghost in the shell' so what's the latest
on your puppet master he's only a puppet
himself section 6 ostensibly pulling the
puppet master strings remains antiquated
stagnant and stuck in the politics of
the old world I'm submitting a formal
complaint about this through the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs
they preserve some power through their
mastery of project to 5:01 but gain
nothing while the puppet master slowly
gained sentience as it Labor's for them
separately the puppet master acts as a
master when it uses his ghost hacking
ability to hijack others and force them
to do its bidding
we see this early in the film when
section 9 interrogate the garbage man
and learns that he was brainwashed into
believing that he was spying on his wife
when in fact he was merely the puppet
masters tool
what's a simulated experience again but
the puppet bastards efforts are
constantly thwarted and it remains
unable to escape the terms of its
bondage
similarly section nines typical MO is
classic master behavior they used lethal
force to accomplish their goals leaving
no room for compromise the first time we
see Batu he's bragging that section nine
has the authority to kill or the ones
our hands dirty and our amok ease
approach to the puppet master is to
destroy it if Kusanagi can't secure it
if you're unable to retrieve the puppet
master your orders are to destroy it
without fail ultimately none of this is
productive it just makes it harder for
section 9 to understand the puppet
masters true nature and prolongs
kusanagi's journey to enlightenment
the preferred result went to opposing
forces clash is synthesis which Hegel
refers to as sublation he means
something very specific here it's
combination without loss
the result is a unique superior idea
that incorporates and accommodates both
perspectives that's what the puppet
master is proposing when he suggests
that he and Kusanagi merged we will both
undergo change but there is nothing for
either of us to lose a cyborg is a great
example of this a cyborg is neither
wholly man or machine it's a synthesis
of man and machine encompassing both
it becomes something new sublation is
crucial because it helps avoid the
stagnation that occurs when a person
idea or whatever becomes too insulated
looking at section 9 we see that the
team was composed with dialectical
principles in mind when togusa
asks Kusanagi why he a nun augmented
human is included on the team of cyborg
badasses
Kusanagi explains that his uniqueness
makes the group stronger if we all
reacted the same way we'd be predictable
and there's always more than one way to
view a situation what's true for the
group is also true for the individual
it's simple over specialize and you
breed and weakness
it's slow death the puppet master too is
aware of the problem of stagnation and
that's why he needs the constraints that
Kusanagi feels fettered by life
perpetuates itself through diversity and
this includes the ability to sacrifice
itself when necessary cells repeat the
process of degeneration and regeneration
until one day they die of bitter aiding
an entire set of memory and information
only genes remain why continually repeat
this cycle simply to survive by avoiding
the weaknesses of an unchanging system
this is reminiscent of a species from
another classic series the Borg from
Star Trek the Borg are an awesome
villain and I use pretty much any excuse
to bring them up but they actually
illustrate what we're talking about
pretty well the Borg is a cybernetic
race that travels the galaxy
assimilating other species into a
collective mind why do they do this it's
the same reason without diversity the
weaknesses of the race will umbria and
compound rendering their civilization
vulnerable obviously from the
perspective of the assimilated there's
some loss the Borg gets your smarts and
fresh genetic material and all you get
is a new modern look but from the
perspective of the Borg it's a story of
developing consciousness captain David
definitely sublation is the climax of
ghosts in the shell not a battle to the
death but rather a synthesis that
results in a stronger more evolved being
because I am now neither the woman who
was known as the major nor am i the
program called the puppet master for
Hegel the progress of human history
happens through conflicts like these
both on an individual level and on a
much larger scale every time we make any
kind of advance through these dialectics
be it in science art or what have you
the world enters a new state of affairs
that should represent an improvement
over what came before Hegel calls this
new state guys the word can be
translated as mind spirit or even and
wait for it ghost so guys in the shell
anyone at the end of the film after
Kusanagi and the puppet master have
merged we have a new state of affairs in
which this type of being exists pull it
a new era call it evolution call it what
you will
it's Geiss to follow
it's trajectory toward and improved
world the film hints at this in the
climactic battle scene when tank fire
obliterates the names of less evolved
creatures in the Tree of Life stopping
at the top on hominids this symbolizes
that evolution must continue even past
human beings this is why ghosts in the
shells message is so unique from other
films in the genre it's not about what
will happen if we do merge with our
technology it's what will happen if we
don't the message is to interact with
the world resolve our contradictions
with it and emerge stronger than we were
before
clinging to our beliefs about what we
are will only prevent us from becoming
what we can be
I want to guarantee that I can still be
myself there isn't one why would you
wish to all things change in a dynamic
environment your effort to remain what
you are is what limits you put another
way resistance is futile may sound bad
coming from the Borg but according to
Hegel sublation is a necessary step
towards progress so it just may be true
stay cool wisecrack peace hey guys
thanks for watching
still a bit confused about Hegel's
master-slave dialectic I don't blame you
Hegel is pretty freakin difficult but
luckily if you're a fan of Naruto I've
got another way to explain it keep in
mind this scenario is entirely
hypothetical let's start at the
beginning
Naruto desperately wants recognition
from the people of the hidden leaf
village by becoming Hokage or the master
ninja of the village let's say that
Naruto uses sweet jutsus and the nine
tailed fox spirit to force people to
make him Hokage by coercing the
villagers to submit to him Naruto has
gained mastery over them in Hegel's
terms they will have become Naruto's
slaves or bondsmen well the problem is
just because he's now Hokage that
doesn't mean he actually has the skills
that doesn't occur until hundreds of
episodes later after he defeats pain in
fact at this point the villagers would
have no choice but to do the bulk of the
protecting and ninja duties while Naruto
just sits back and takes all the credit
in other words if the people are having
to fight invaders build defenses and
craft weapons then they are the ones
gaining the skills becoming of sweet
sweet Hokage is essentially Naruto will
never get any bed
at being Hokage while his subordinates
are becoming more and more skilled at
the art of Defense so even though in
this hypothetical situation Naruto would
be the Hokage his claim to mastery is
slowly dissipated as the villagers come
to master the skills that supposedly
define his role as Hokage
so who's the master and who's the slave
thanks again to Naruto online the
officially licensed RPG by Bandai Namco
for helping make this video possible and
some of us around wisecrack have been
playing Naruto online for days it's got
really intuitive gameplay an animation
that feels like you're in the anime it
has all the staples you'd expect that of
an RPG turn-based combat character
progression a storyline that remains
pretty faithful to the anime and some
damn amazing cutscenes creating your own
shinobi running around with your arms
behind your back leveling up learning
kick-ass jutsus and creating a battle
team from the classic Naruto characters
it's entertaining as hell it's
browser-based
and free-to-play so be sure to check it
out at the links in the description and
if you want to play with one of our
writers Matt his user name is Geno Rayne
the surfer he's on is in the description
too so if you run into him tell him I
said yo and of course don't forget to
subscribe and ring that bell to get
notified when we upload new stuff
thanks guys peace
[Music]